Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Subnautica".
Now a lot of you guys were mad at me,
'Cause I didn't actually hit "Use" on this doll here, so...
(High Pitched Mark Scream From The Depths)
(Held Back Laughter From Mark)
Is this for real?
(MiniMusicMan - "Crazy La Paint" Starts Playing)
Ah, ha, ha...
I've never hit this before.
Aww that's so cute.
(Mark doll Coughing? Screaming?)
(Light Chuckle)
I don't even know if I could make that scream if I tried.
[Mark Doll] NO!
[Mark Doll] Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Subnautica".
(Mark Chuckles)
Ah, that's so cute.
(Mark doll makes a girly scream)
Aww that's SO CUTE!
Wow, Okay.
I'm gonna take you with me-
I'm putting you on Big Box Barry
But uh, I'll come get you in a bit because i don't have time for Big Box Barry.
Hey look, my shit's back!
Okay, so what I gotta d- Oh..
...WHERE'S BUBBLEBUTT?
-Did I not dock Bubblebutt?
Bubblebutt, Bubblebutt!
(Mark noises)
Bumblebutt, you can't run away from me like that!
You'll get lost.
Okay, so I know where the seed locations are.
They may be a bit of a bitch to find, but at least I know where to go for them.
So the Membrane Seed- the Membrane Tree in fact, is actually... somewhere in the Grand Reef.
So I'm gonna go find that right-OH!
Hidey Hidey Hidey-Ho, Are you what I'm looking for?
Oh my god, you are, aren't you?
Heey. Hi!
If I scan you- OHH!
OHHHH!
(Marki-giggle)
So, this is the first of four ingredients.
I didn't see this in the biome in there, so I didn't think it was gonna be in there.
You got a membr-AAHH!
HEY!
DICKHOLE!!!
It's been awhile since- Woah hey woah-
WHY AM I INSIDE OF YOU??
Where is he?
WHERE'D HE GO??
Alright anyway, so we got the first of four.
The other three are in various locations throughout the entire ocean of Subnautica.
Now conveniently for me, two of them are easily accessible.
The third, or the fourth, is gonna be a bit of a BIIIITCH to be able to get.
Because, it is.. rare, to say the least.
I believe there's only about-
mmmm uh maybeee-
-So there's only about a handful of the last plant in the entirety of this ocean.
Which is kinda weeeird-
Oh that is a ship. I- I totally forgot there were pieces of the ship all of the place because of that.
Boy oh boy, it's great to be back in Bumblebutt.
Ohh, Bumblebutt is so SPEEDY!
Ohh you're so speedy, I love you! (kiss noise)
I don't remember the music being so ominous-
But then again, it's been awhile since I've been up and exploring the upper area of Subnautica.
Ugh..
I don't like tha-  Oh hey here is the crev-ASSE!
Alright, so down in this crevasse, is something that I need..
...There aren't any leviathans down there, are there?
I always hate going down into these areas because it's just so unnatural..
Like everything in here just looks so freaking WEIRD!
I believe this is what I'm looking for, isn't it?
Isn't this what I'm-YEAH! Gabe's feather!
It's Gabe's feather!
Now I don't know why these are gonna use the hatching enzymes,
But, Hey, I'm not gonna question it when it's right in front of my face.
BOINK! Got that!
♫ Get in Bumblebutt then you go- ♫
Okay, so I've got two seeds! Which is good-
'Cause I believe I only need one of each of these,
And none of the others.
Now the third one is in an interesting l- Oh..
..Interesting location.
It's actually on the back of the Reefbacks.
So it's a good thing I'm not bringing Big Box Barry, or else they'll ask for child support from him-
But don't worry about that, I'm gonna go ask very nicely if I can borrow some of the other things..
..From the back of their ass.
Oh.. this isn't normal dark..
This is..advanced darkness.
Hello- OH hi! Hello!
Oh- There you are! I was looking at the moon!
You're just so pretty,  y'know whenever I see the moon I think of you 'cause you're so equivalently beautiful.
-Hey you mind if I scrape some seeds off the back of your ass?
Uh.. I'm just gonna assume that it's somewhere here and try to scan what I can.
Hey don't mind me back here!
You just- If you feel a tickling sensation, that's just me getting frisky.
Don't you worry!
Alright, so that's not it..
Regi- (giggle) Reginald..
Is that it? No, that's Table Coral..
Is that it- Ugh.. It's Redwart.
Yeah you got some Redwart back here, lady!
I dunno how to tell you this, but uh..
(Laughs) I guess Barry left you with another present.
Ooh, pulsating.
-No, it's nothing. Oh that's part of you.
..Furled Papyrus.
(Mark-noise of disgust)
Wait- Where is- Oh.
God, Bumblebutt why are you so far away??
Eugh- Oh I forgot I had this.
Euh-heheh-
..Alright.
Alright, so I don't know if you're just lacking in the seed department,
But I'm gonna go.. Haha, I'm sorry, I have a boyfriend.
How 'bout you? Heeey big sexy, what you got on yo ass?
Ohh yeah.
Hey, that looks special! Is that what I'm looking for?
Yeah? Ro-Rouge!
Rouge! That's what I'm looking for!
Oh gimme some of that rouge, baby.
Oh yeah rou-AH HEY!
WHO'S DOIN' THAT??
WHAT THE HELL??
WHAT WAS THAT?
WHAT HIT ME? WAUGH!!
Oh you- Oh god damn it, okay. Fuck you.
Alright lemme breach here, because, ugh-
It's so dark!
It's so unquestionably dark!
Ugh!
Alright I guess I'll make it back towards my lifepod, which I can't believe is still floating after all these YEARS.
..That I've been under the water.
And if the sun could come up-OH! Is that the sun coming up? Oh thank you.
-But that is already three of four. We are almost underway to be able to get to the Hatching Enzymes.
But the last one.. Might be a bit-
Oh!
'Scuse me! Were you just uh...
Having some private time with that pillar?
I'm sorry for disturbing you.
Ah. Oh I can see!
Oh, I can see!
Ain't that lovely.
Oh and it looks like my lifepod- Oh..
My god, what happened to my webcam? Holy shit!
What the fuck!
Okay I've returned from being abducted by aliens, apparently!
I have no idea what happened. My camera freaked out.
I thought it was the capture card, but no.
My camera was just borked(?)
And I don't know why, but if it happens again..
..OH WELL!
This is the mushroom forest near the Koosh Zone.
But I gotta be IN the Koosh Zone to be able to get it
And I have a funny feeling it's gonna be very hard to spot.
I uh- I have a vauge idea of what it looks like?
Kinda thin, papery?
Doesn't look like it'd put up much of a fight?
Everybody keep your eyes peeled! I'm gonna need your help on this one.
Just shout, really loudly.
Don't even bother writing in the comments, just shout.
Woah- Hey Hey HEY Hey Hey!
I don't like the look of you!
Yeah I'm calling you butt-fuck ugly!
There seems to be a lot of life-
A lot of activity happening down in the deep blue sea!
Woah-ho-ho!
Hey now!
Woah!
Aagh. Ah- Sorry!
Ooh- Woah! You just appear out of nowhere!
I'm just coasting along all la-di-fucking-da and then you pop out of nobody!
I'm not seeing anything there..
Sorry! Just tryin' to get by, man. Just tryin' to get by.
I mean I know you were too, and now you're dead. But yknow.
I consider myself to be very important.
I'm a YouTuber don'tcha know! And AS a YouTuber, I have an excessively high opinion of myself!
Hey hey, Get out of the way!
I think I see it! Is that it?
That looks like it! Wait, hang on-
Sea crown! -Is that it? I have no idea if that's what I'm looking for, but I think it is!
If it is, HOORAY!
I gotta hurry!
YAY!
I GOT A SEED, I DONT KNOW IF IT'S THE RIGHT ONE-
ohh, Get it in the bucket, ohhh get it in the bucket!
Okay! Alright! We're off!
SQUADALA!
We've got all four.
Which means we can make the Hatching Enzyme. I literally think we don't need anything else-
-BUT THOSE to be able to hatch.
I mean- this is it! I mean this is it!!
Like, this is IT!
This is it!
This is what I've been waiting for!
And I don't know if this is gonna help me get off of this island,
But, it should help me at least cure the virus
which means that I can afford more time.
Which is the biggest crisis in this game right now.
This disease is gonna kill me no matter what I do.
The life in this- like, I actually learned
that the life around this, uh,
around this base, the only reason why life is here, is because
The Sea Emperor has been able to transfer.. some of it's- Oh..
..Some of it's enzyme 42.. to the surrounding waters of this area
because of the alien Precursor Tubing System,
that allowed the Peepers to go around.
Everywhere else on this entire planet is DEAD.
There is no life, not a scrap of it, anywhere to be found elsewhere.
So, all of my dreams of there being giant Leviathans bigger than we've ever seen before in the distance..
That can't happen.
That won't happen.
It just won't happen, because every other area on this entire planet
was killed by the Karar virus.
Can I send my Seamoth through here?
Can I, please- Please tell me Bumblebutt can come me me!
HEY!
Please tell me Bumblebutt's not about to be crushed!
Oh!
Ah?
I'm here.
..That was scary, but I made it!
Okay!
Okay, and my Seamoth is not exploding, so that's good to know.
Okay! Hey, Emperor!
I'm back, and I've got a special present for you that I think you're going to like very much.
So if I take..
A-this, and a-that,
and switch out this toy car for good luck!
Switch one of those..
Stick some titanium in there..
And then... One more of this.. I have everything.
HOUH, THIS IT IT!!
MMMMMM-
Alright, I don't know what this is gonna lead to, it might be anti-climactic, but I don't know.
Insert hatching enz- Oh wait, no, do I have to make that?
AH SHIT, AGH FUCK.
AGGH I gotta make it! Ah, I-
(Mark is frustrated)
I'll be back! I'm sorry- yes, the wink.
I'll be back, I'm sorry.
I forgot about that. I forgot. I gotta take my sea moth through there again.
Really questionable decision  of sending the sea moth all the way through.
Here we go anyway though. Whatever. What could happen?
ha ha HAH
*Mark gibberish*
We're at the base of the aurora.
That's- ah
oh
oooh
You're such a worrier! Don't do it.
heeeeeyy. Pod Five.
loh? LAH? LAAH? LAH LAH LOCKED?!
EXCUSE
WHY. WELL
oh I got the right hatching enzymes
THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
Was that normal?!
Sploosh!
Get some peepers and eat em and mmmh
Boomerang!
mmmmh some piss to wash it down.
eeerggh duh- SPLOOOSH
Squib buh buh. Squib bah bah-
okay, we're ready to go, let's go do this bad boy.
Scubalee doo bah do ba do bah dee dooh!
This is it.
Now, it's it.
it was it before, I got you all hyped up for no reason, but this is it.
I have the hatching enzymes. I don't know what they're gonna do
and I don't know if it's actually going to be final. I'm prepared to be disappointed in that regard
but I came all this way and I did it of my own volition.
with you guys' help, I got these hatching enzymes. I made it from the very first crash
all the way to now. And this may not even be the end because I still haven't escaped.
But if it heals me, and I'm gonna take off my gloves, just so I can see what happens.
but if it heals me, if I look at my hands-Oh, its not so bad!
but if I scan myself, I bet I have...
Yeah I'm infected. But,
let's see what happens.
*deep breath*
wooh!
hi? OH! HI!
OOOOOOHHH!!
OH!
oh- I can- I ca- I'm trying to scan you so badly
oh it's not working. there we go.
OOOOOHH!!
OOOOHHH!!!
oh my god!
look at 'em go! They're tiny and adorable!
oh, they're not one hundred percent functioning prop-
oh, go to your mama!
oh, go to your mama!!
oh!
it's beautiful!
awh it's beautiful!
Mama!
it worked!
I can't believe it worked!
What is that?
aaawwh!
oh, they're goin' to mama!
aaaaahhh
oh, they're going to mama!
oooohh
eh!
I forgot about that.
hang on, what is that?
oh, baby leviathan enzymes. Not yet implemented.
Man, I got chills from that!
I have goose bumps!
AH!
so by saving the babies you-
the mom dies?! It's like-
It's like with a squid? like, the parents die every time their-
their babies are born? Like they spend so much energy just-
surviving long enough for the next generation.
oh, that's so sad.
so I- jus- I don't wanna leave!
I can't just leave, but the babies are already gone!
I guess you just follow the glow
She's been here for a thousand years.
She's been holding onto life, for a thousand years.
hoping beyond hope, that some one would come along, and save her children
That's so sad.
an- and so beautiful at the same time.
I guess I just gotta say good bye.
I'm honestly emotional about that. I honestly am.
Like if there's one thing that always gets me like that, in terms of, like, emotional stuff,
it's- it's always the concept of sacrifice.
So I highly doubt-
I highly doubt that they're over here yet.
I'm just trying to glance around and- ooh!
I'm just trying to glance around
and hope I don't run into 'em like that!
what's the story-
I don't even know if this worked. Did this work?
nope, still infected because-
ah I pissed myself!
cause it hasn't been implemented yet.
and I think- I really am happy that you guys waited with me for that because
it was- it was a big decision to be like- be at the precipice of that and be like,
"hey I could do this," right then and there but it wouldn't have been worth it. And even now, like its not fully
implemented, but that's so much better than what I was gonna do, like if I had cheated
and you know, saw- seen the end there...
But anyway, that is the end of Subnautica
for now.
again, like with the last time I left this series, uh,
we're waiting.
we're waiting for the full release of the game. And now that I've seen this, you know,
I think now I will. I'll wait for the full release to the game. Because it's only gonna be like September
until the game actually gets fully released. So it's not gonna be that long, but it'll be long enough to give this
a breather, and let this rest. Because, I think this is the best ending that we could've hoped for.
In an ideal world, we wouldve seen how, you know, we would've been cured and we would've seen
the children playing here in the safe shallows. And who knows, they may be here but
that's better than what we were gonna leave on.
and I feel good about this.
I really do.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching,
Subnautica will return when there is the full release of the game.
And thank you so much for joining me on this journey, I hope you enjoyed it as much as I did.
And I hope you're satisfied with it, until there's more yet to come.
So thank you again everybody so much for watching,
And as always, I will see you, in the next video!
BUH-BYE!